prime minister the issue of children
arriving on small boats should children
in the care of the home office have the
same protections under the children act
as those in local Authority care
so it kind of I mean first of all look I
I the government everyone takes the
welfare of children incredibly seriously
as of course we should and it's
important that when it comes to this
policy that we're sensitive and that we
get it right and there's been a lot of
thought that's gone into getting it
right and I think we've got a policy
that does what we need it to do which is
treats people with decency treats people
humanely safeguards Children's Welfare
but also achieves the objectives that
we're trying to achieve which is to
break the cycle of these criminal gangs
and stop people
coming here who shouldn't be coming here
and also some of them tragically dying
on Route including children and I think
we struck the right balance in all of
those things so was that a no that there
shouldn't be equal protections under the
children's act I think there are a set
of I mean you Bruno is better than me I
think there are a set of very specific
laws that we have around corporate
parenting the distinguish between the
home office and local authorities which
you would know better than me but in all
cases the welfare of children is taken
seriously Safeguard is taken seriously
there is support and procedures in place
to make sure children are looked after
properly in all circumstances thank you
the safeguarding of children is indeed
and in 2011 the independent family
returns panel was set up to safeguard
children in family units who were being
removed from the UK
their role has been disapplied from this
coming Friday so what measures will
there be in place to safeguard children
who are being removed as part of a
family unit
so as well I mean children are not
separated from families and they will be
it made sure that the facilities for
them and the accommodation for them is
absolutely appropriate for them
oversight of that
well in the first instance it would be
the home office in terms of the when
people arrive in the provision of those
facilities if you're asking from a legal
perspective so in 2011 the home office
brought in a panel specifically to
oversee the safeguardia yeah no yes so I
mean the home office can do that itself
okay so it no longer needs the
independent family returns panel at all
no it's not I mean we've got advice
we've put in place procedures and the
home office perfectly capable of doing
that okay where specifically were family
groups so children with their parents
who are scheduled for removal be
detained in appropriate accommodation
for them and they won't be separated
from their families how much of that
accommodation is currently available at
the moment there are a few thousand
places and more are being built and
there's a full team at the home office
that is working on the Opera
operationalization of the bill and
that's one of the things that they're
working through to make sure that it's
ready at the time the bill is in force a
few thousand places overall for capacity
but as I said for families no no overall
right so specifically for families I
don't have an exact number but the point
is that they will be they will be
accommodated specifically in
accommodation that's appropriate for
them and children would not be separated
from families no one will see that but
there will be powers to detain children
with their families that the the
intention of this part of the policy you
know the policy objective here is is not
to detain children but it's important
that we don't inadvertently create a
policy that incentivizes people to bring
children who wouldn't otherwise come
here and that's why it's important that
it applies equally to families because
otherwise you increase the likelihood
that people bring children here they
make very dangerous Crossings I don't
think anyone would want to see that
that's not good for children
um so the policy should and must apply
to families but it's right for them we
then look at families differently as we
do and they should be in accommodation
that's appropriate for them and that
those family groups should not be
separated I think that is that is the
right thing to do because otherwise you
know you create it as I said you create
an incentive for a criminal gang to tell
people to bring a child with them when
they otherwise wouldn't be and I don't
think that is a good thing I don't think
we want to create a pull factor to make
it more likely that children are being
making this very perilous journey in
conditions that are appalling I don't
think that's the right thing to do we
should not create a system that makes
that more likely no I think you're
absolutely right we shouldn't be
creating a system that makes that more
likely I'm interested in what measures
are going to be put in place to assess
vulnerabilities particularly under uh
those who have protected characteristics
so what measures to ascertain whether
women are pregnant whether people have
disabilities what protections there will
be for lgbtq people
so I mean well one of the things to do
first of all there's age
um actually is the first thing we've
talked about children so I think the
first thing is to make sure that we're
able to ascertain who our children and
need that extra safeguarding and the
nationality and borders Act established
a new decision-making function in the
home office
um
referred to as the national age
assessment board which will consist of
expert social workers
um who will conduct things like age
assessments on on full referral I think
that's a really important thing but it's
not easy and those things are complex
but it's right that we get those right
and I said the powers in the now but
will allow us to do that more properly
than what we do it properly anyway but
just to do that it even more
comprehensively than we currently do it
will age assessments also be carried out
on older people
I think there's a well we have a I think
we have an initial way that we do age
assessments that the Supreme Court I
think unanimously said
um was lawful I think the reforms
through the nabba aim to make it more
comprehensive and more consistent and
robust from the outset as I said
there'll be expert social workers and
we're also considering how scientific
age assessment age settlement methods
could um could widen the evidence
available to decision makers and I think
the um there's a committee that's also
published uh a report very recently
which the home office are currently
considering so the home offices adults
at risk policy which was last updated in
November of last year considered that
anyone over the age of 70 would be at
greater risk if they were detained
does that mean that people over 70 will
be excluded from the provisions of the
illegal migration bill because they
would be at greater risk if they were
detained
you know I haven't seen that report
Carol I apologize so I can't comment on
if I happily get back to you on it okay
thank you
um a final question from me so I've been
greatly exercised about how we're going
to afford protection to those who might
have been eligible under the arap scheme
or the Afghan citizens resettlement
scheme
should they have not managed to leave
Afghanistan at the time of all pitting
and when the Arab scheme was in full
flow so what are we going to do to make
sure that those people who may well have
assisted the UK forces are not going to
be removed to Afghanistan and how are we
going to determine them should they
arrive here by small boat or have
already arrived here by small Bay
um so look we've already
I think we've already welcomed over 20
000 people across the two schemes we
have specifically for those from
Afghanistan Arab and acrs I think we I
think on on our but I think we're about
12 000 and there's not a cat scheme and
from memory and but there are
commitments to those specific people
that we've um that we've made you know
my understanding is that you know we
have a way to talk to these people and
communicate with them
um and we in Afghanistan and then we'll
bring them here in a safe and legal way
and also through acrs you know there's
been there's three different Pathways of
that where people are leaving
Afghanistan and then we'll we'll come
here as well but you know so far as I
said over 20 23 000 already with a plan
to keep going
um but I think part of the actually
illustrates the overall issue we've got
in the those are exactly people who we
want to help which is why an Afghan flag
and it was highlighted in the
independent
as having been given notification that
he was likely to be removed to Rwanda
yeah it's hard for me to comment on the
individual case but if you send it to me
I'll happily make sure the home office
have a look but I think the general
point I'd make is you know it's right
that we have a migration system and an
asylum policy that targets our
generosity our compassion our resources
on the people that are most vulnerable
the people that we determine we want to
welcome here accepting that we're never
going to be able to bring everyone here
who would like to come here I think
everyone will acknowledge that and so
there's always difficult decisions to
make we want to make sure that we do
Target all of our power our compassion
our generosity on those who we really
want to and at the moment what we have
as a system well that's not happening
where you know we have tens of thousands
of people coming illegally who are not
in that category you know a third of all
small boat arrivals last year came from
Albania clearly it's not a system that
is targeted on the people who most need
our help and that's a system that I
think we probably agree we want to get
to and once we have proper control of
our borders once the bill delivers what
we needed to deliver then we're going to
be able to do a far better job of having
comprehensive safe and legal rules in
targeting as I said all compassion our
generosity our resources on those who we
most want to help in that type of
country we are that's what we've done in
Spades over the last few years in Syria
and Afghanistan and elsewhere and that's
what we will always do but at the moment
our ability to do that is limited by
what's happening due to Illegal
migration
is it right that an Afghan female judge
or MP who arrives on a small boat should
be treated differently to an Afghan
female judge or MP who arrived here
prior to this legislation
I think again wrong again vocations the
point is we we have to break the cycle
of criminal gang as we have to stop
people dying when they are trying to
make these dangerous Journeys and we've
got to have a system which is fair for
everybody fair for taxpayers fair on
those who emigrate here legally Fair on
those who most need our help and that
means we have to have a system which
says if you do come here illegally
having crossed through multiple safe
countries on your way
then it's reasonable that we detain you
and remove you to a safe alternative
let's just forget what are we doing here
we are making sure that people are
looked after they will be safe that will
either be in their home country whether
if that's appropriate for them all
Rwanda or other Alternatives down the
line you know that is a policy which is
reasonable it's fair and will ensure
that we can break the cycle of criminal
gangs continue to welcome
refugees here who we want to provide
that Sanctuary for and stop people dying
needlessly you know that is a system
that we want to move to and this is what
the bill will deliver
thank you
um
Sarah Champion the overseas development
assistance committee thank you chair
um prime minister recently you've been
speaking a lot about fairness and last
year you authorized an estimated 3.5
billion pounds of our overseas aid
budget to support refugees in the UK and
particularly on Hotel accommodation
managed by the home office
um you just said that you support
refugees coming here I think that's
absolutely the right thing to do but
you're using the aid budget to do it and
in doing so you're effectively turning
your back on the poorest in the world by
not addressing the very drivers that
force them to flee their homes so how
how is that approach Fair
um I you know I I think I'm very proud
of our record on Aid We're the third
largest donor in the G7 as a percentage
of GDP historically been a very
significant Aid donor and the way in
which we spend our Aid money is entirely
in line with the oecd's DAC committee's
guidelines on that as you'll be aware so
we follow all those guidelines and
indeed the Autumn statement last year
made additional money available to deal
with a particular circumstances of
Ukraine and also Afghanistan but
primarily Ukraine my question was on um
fairness yes it's within the guidelines
but it's not within the morality that
the guidelines expect us to follow and
no other G7 country is spending to that
level so I wonder your decision to
prioritize Aid spending in the UK
um and not therefore internationally it
has put immense strain on our support
for fragile countries around the world
to give you one example at very short
notice your government decided to cut
funding to to a save the children
project in Afghanistan which is
currently supporting a hundred thousand
women and girls they're now going to
have to wind that project up why are you
cutting Aid to Afghanistan when the
country is undergoing such a massive
humanitarian crisis and of course women
and girls are at the front of that
having their rights stripped away from
them
in the interest of being being brief
because I I know we need to get a lot to
do but you know I'll stay at the chair
stare at the beginning is that we are
one of the largest vendors on Aid
anywhere in the world
internationally and that that is the
reality of it our track record on this
is uh is very very strong and goes about
Harry's question right at the beginning
and clearly people like to spend more on
lots of things because the incumbent is
to say well where's that money meant to
come from
um but with regard to Afghanistan in
particular
um you know we are a leading donor to
the situation in Afghanistan I think
we've committed something like 200
million pounds since spring of last year
at least you talk about women and girls
at least half
um uh of those that we reach with our
interventions in Afghanistan should be
women and girls and we also co-hosted a
very successful um pledging Summit
alongside Germany and Qatar last year
which raised over two billion dollars
for the un's Afghanistan appeal